employing significant and he knocking it
wants it right away that is the cream we
know he's gonna pull it back and just
obliterate is this real that's almost no
trophy is could would pop up to listen
for that job be Charlie laughing OH
device takes down a headshot jump in
midair from scream who else would learn
that headshot techniques now in a real
tricky position bomb planted in his
favor but there's two people lining up
the shots from screen finds another hat
it's happened in this round be [ __ ]
great back to survive double peg looking
so good oh my good scream they fight
before the rotation come in Guardian
gets RPG that's their last Pope's award
long and it's cream on a fast wrote a
pacifically least get one now to the
Paul George plays did it scream again
he's gonna get another it seemed less
though because these have found
existence alone if you do that that's
warhead truck he's in the president
there's nothing they can do what around
from screams doesn't matter change it's
good if you like that flank from before
Oh screams we have to take two quick
entries there but he's alone completely
alone but he will take another kill
Detroit the closest one wall by God
scream is there with our pop flies
weirdly social sick it goes off but they
are in the correct angle to deal with it
still wins it overs and snacks the VP
continue to press forward onto the
betimes extreme holding the line cream
with the triple headshot to stop in a
cold breeze back if you want know any
cookin cases do you in the damage to the
open come from Michael a lose Lauren she
has got a bit of a chest infection and
can barely breathe so that's why we are
sometimes burning up in the mean Connor
a second dream picture sound to this
could very well be a very very
oppressive round llamado and to see
peace now [ __ ] prick and now me go to
have the limelight and screen wants it
back
this is a man you
no challenge like this every time I got
to watch him teach you things like that
go down lower yeah and same thing to do
yeah that stuff with us that's a great
place and it's rad this ready punishes
that oh my god
dependency she gets creamed he has come
back with a vengeance springing some
punishment back yeah oh of course it's
Smith's it's always mr. gets those shots
always come from early on they did play
they what it's working that passive
style but now you can be streamed as a
character board screens doing their own
sex for quick access and the age and a
little bit messy is the CP so three
flights on a straight three one another
doing a bit of damage to each other
makeup screen with his a cake even
because with our faces one at a time we
know only babies like between are plain
water days pay
you messed up